is there a One That Got Away for you
guys
okay this is so weird yeah because
literally I just got everything
yesterday okay like yesterday night I
was really deep in life and then this
one was like you know what okay you said
you're 18 you're only 18. yeah okay I've
had a lot of like I've had a lot of
experiences because yeah okay but I I
think what's your body count
that's not answer for today
I'm curious okay can you answer this
question please it's Kristen what you
just said
I'm not asking on this podcast right now
I mean you you basically said like you
actually said you're a hoe yeah you said
that and you said you've been a bad man
I don't think it's going to cause any
more damage
you kind of told everyone anyway
I'm expecting like 20 plus yeah
you want 20 plus
I want to say one thing though who
doesn't just mean to me no sex please
yeah I've been through this
fools
no I've had five today
so to clarify yeah so if if if you I
didn't hear that bit but you don't said
she refers to her so she's a bit because
different ages here it might like from
my age range if I that makes you at home
as you get older there's different
categories but oh no no that's not
flirting that's just practicing to be a
whole that's a chain you know don't you
think so you're getting getting demanded
me so you understand oh man's mind work
so you don't want to twist them up and
do your thing with this and that that No
One's Gonna know like come on check to a
beggar man that's still a form of
cheating big dog no matter how you look
at it how is it cheating if you're
single
a real single so I see this leading on
Wednesday No Man's because I never
sometimes yeah like for example the
other day boy started telling me send me
some long paragraph about how he likes
me this and that I aired it and I was
like oh why and I just like I kept
adding the question and then the other
day I was like I can't I can't do this I
don't like you and he's like yeah yeah
but I had that lead you on because I
never specifically said I liked you I
never backed up in the way guys look at
it so if you're like talking to them on
a regular basis it's like yeah you're
taking I never confirmed it you may not
have confirmed it but it's still your
YouTube and you're young so this is kind
of like when I was younger I didn't
really understand this either but like
men and women can't be friends they're
not your friends the only reason they're
talking they're they're trying they're
trying no okay yeah and I promise you
and I promise you I promise you I
promise you if you were 300 pounds they
would not be your friend I'm telling you
I have got genuine where friends
can I can I just give this girl a bit of
advice in future like don't introduce
yourself as a whole okay I just going
forward yeah moving forward introduce
yourself just just put you in it no but
it wasn't it I think I'm trying to
explain something
what's wrong you see you see this is
what I say to the man them yeah if you
attract work young and you don't get the
[__] you know we tear out the [__] off
if I don't get a [__] you know
impatience where's your picnic in your
wife what where's your picnics
I don't believe in marriage you don't
know my age
just one thing I never do no no no do
you one day do you want to settle down
and get him and get a woman yeah I'm not
getting married so are you gonna do that
if you don't [__] you after the first
week
all right so how are you gonna find your
woman how are you going to find yourself
so you don't care
so if you like someone so much and she
don't [__] you after the Eighth Day
You're Gonna Leave Her all right I said
A week
I'll explain this to you like from the
guy's point of view like most girls from
the guy's point of view it's like most
girls there's someone you've let sleep
with you quickly at some point in your
life what about the guys okay okay it's
not the point that's not the point at
some point let's wait wait okay you got
it you gotta wait at some point in your
life most girls have let someone sleep
with them quickly so from the guy's
point of view if if you're not if you're
making him wait a long time you're just
not that guy and and I do interviews all
the time with girls on the street and
like they'll like I had a girl the other
day she said she told me if I'm at Bruno
Mars tomorrow it would be on it would be
because that's the one I think because
of his Fame but I feel like for me I've
recently started talking to subscriber
and we've been talking and I feel like
I'm not ready to give him the problem
yet because I want to keep him running
style do you like him do you like him
see that's why that's why let me tell
you something yeah
but let me tell you something from a
man's point of view yeah
like you could be in a situation yeah
where you've met a girl and
she don't know about
my brother air I don't know him off
camera but he might have done something
over there yeah but he might I just she
might not overblacked him so she just
cut you her prerogative in it she just
wanted to beat so she just beat in it
I've come along now yeah she's thinking
raw
she likes him like she likes man she
wants to she don't want to come across
in a certain way to man so now she got
along at the Pom-Pom man so what I'm
saying for my man's point of view is
like hold on a minute you're taking man
for Egypt that's how a man looks no he's
not looking at me like that no but I'm
saying in that situation a man
last week no but I just wanted to [__]
you no but I'm not saying
you're using sex you're using you're
using sex as a weapon to get committed
on the first night I feel like instantly
he'll be like you know what I've had
them
coming across his wife
and that's and that and that's and
that's fair if you are Wi-Fi
let me stop stop if that's fair if you
are wifey and if you have never done
that but most men like they can kind of
get a vibe from a girl and they're like
you know what she's probably done that
at a certain age she's probably done
that with someone for free so why why am
I I haven't [__] for money yeah I can
say that I have done it for free
whatever I've done you you know what I'm
saying though like at some point at some
point she has she has done that for a
guy that hasn't taken her on a date
stop interrupting me you've done it like
four times if you do it again you can't
stay on okay so at some point she has
done it for free at some point she has
done it for a guy that She chased or
that that she didn't have to take that
he didn't have to take her on a date and
so you're gonna have the next guy do all
of this because of your past trauma yeah
but no I wouldn't I wouldn't just like
see a guy just because he's gonna take
One A Day XYZ not every guy that I have
seen I've been like oh let me make him
wait X Y and Z because I like
how old are you how old are you I'm 23.
okay at some point has there been a guy
that you haven't made weight that long
well I was previously an eight-year
relationship and I've got a child and
I've left here but have you had the one
that's done I've met I've met a guy once
yeah and then I've spoke to him on
social media I met him ended up sleeping
with him and realizing he wasn't the one
so it has happened so that's right which
is which is fine I'm not I'm not saying
like that you do that often but I'm
saying if you've done that once for
someone the guys see that as
disrespectful because you're gonna make
this next guy get to know you and do all
this stuff when you gave it to the last
guy
sometimes I feel like sometimes when you
have it I feel like there's levels
levels to it so if there's someone that
you genuine lack there's some some guys
out here and be like you know what babes
I just wanna [__] I don't want a
relationship I don't want to settle down
I just want to [__] and that's up to the
woman if she feels like she wants stuff
up too but I feel like it's different
aspects if you're actually wanting to
get to know that person and and the
foundation with that person but that's
what my woman's point of view right who
is here to judge me if that's no but I
didn't say touch you yeah no but I'm
saying in general from my man's point of
view like that's why I said it's your
prerogative I'm just saying for my man's
perspective yeah this is how in general
like men look on things you say I'm just
say let me flip it on his head down here
from a woman's perspective now yeah say
like your day and a man that puts his
business on social media in terms of
when he's seeing a girl you know about
his life it's on is what I'm saying
they'll go on dates he'll post it if
he's buying her things he'll post it and
he's that type of guy where he's taking
an uptown regular he buys a little gifts
regular he pulls it regular you've seen
that previously yeah him and the girl's
done now yeah you and him start talking
now so boom now you've like so imagine
now he just wants to come and chill out
your yard he's not on no I'm telling you
now majority of girls will have an issue
that could not be saying hold on a
minute I've seen you taking kaisha
Uptown
what's going on like but hold on you
just want to come around and watch
Netflix and chill and Boom Beach we beat
that hold on dead that's what I'm trying
to say so with a man it's the same thing
if a man knows a girl has like
previously and I'm not saying there's
nothing wrong with it from a man's
perspective as previously except with X
Y instead maybe not on the first night
but you know I mean that pretty soon
first night second night whatever and
then with him she's trying to do like
the get to know I'm not saying there's a
problem with that because from her
perspective it's from the writer that
she's thinking now I want to settle down
but from his perspective you're taking
him for you A big dog you know what you
just say it's so cool I mentioned a few
things and I always got this thing you
know I've done this in the past I'm not
doing it again fam why are you gonna
tell me that you was home with me are
you a map
this is Jesus
I've done that bro I mean all of it if
you told me that you [__] two [__]
before you're bad believe I'm not gonna
ask you to [__] a chick with me I want
all of that [__] but are these women
saying it just off the Casper are you
asking them the questions
are you [__] uh yeah well like at
this moment are you [__] no not right
now no not right the second don't come
back
yes
when is last time you [__]
um
but in general if his approach in
general would not work the man that say
in the sweet nothings to her you're
beautiful and all that in general that
would work
nobody I'm saying in general like women
would say they want what you're saying
blunt honesty like yo I just want to
bend you over right now but hear what
I'm saying majority of time you're sexy
you know it depends what night it is
but you know what it is
going up what you said yeah you know the
majority of girls yeah yeah would think
what you just said in their head don't
be touched but you see their response
will be different to what they think
yeah but if the Hennessy is involved
anyway but maybe because everybody yeah
it's kind of like it's kind of like um
okay imagine if you bought a purse right
and you've spent 500 on a purse
and you three you bought same Pairs and
I I came in and I said I got the same
purse for 150. gasp would you be kind of
salty yeah but sex is no Karma sex is
not the same thing as me yeah it is
okay okay let's let's flip it let's flip
it okay as a woman imagine
oh okay you found out you're dating a
guy and you found out like like he
bought you let's say a hundred dollars
something for your birthday and you find
out his ex-girlfriend he rented out a
whole club threw her a whole party
invited all of her friends
how would you kick off but in my head
yeah
and at first and at first right you you
would be excited for the hundred dollar
gift and you would think oh wow this
this guy's so nice until until
you find out about his ex that he did
all of that that's the equivalent for
guys
to add on to that yeah because I
mentioned something similar when I said
like you've seen a guy dating experience
online and he's doing all the Uptown
stuff then with you he just wants to
Netflix and chill at your house like
you're gonna think huh and even to to go
for that point you can take it with with
it's a it's another reason why men not
like a girl that's very active like
dating wise and sexually wise because if
you're active dating wise you're gonna
have more there's more charts of you
having those experiences where you're
getting the the big money purses and
whatnot and what not and it's just
natural that when the next man comes
along now you might not have that but if
a man wants to do that he would do that
no but he might not have that okay he
might not have it then that's fine and
then but but it's it's not always
fighting for the majority of women
because now you're thinking hold on a
minute I've been used to my last
birthday no but you can have your own
but on your last birthday your man took
you X Y and Z this birthday I must buy
in a Chinese saying yo that's true
we've had a girl yeah that is doing the
most in the bedroom like doing the most
like because you're sexually active bro
then you've got a next thing good girl
in that you like her been in the bedroom
she can't really Arch her back and then
things
if a girl puts out on the first date you
wife in it yeah if the [__] is good
what was my problem yeah I wouldn't say
no I wouldn't say no no but for me
that's a red flag cause you imagine what
if she only slept with you on the first
date there you go what if it was you no
I was the only person yeah first time I
wouldn't believe it I wouldn't believe
it no I understand that I like it as
well you know all the time we get into
things about the bodycon watch your body
come big dog
see man ain't got a clue
[Music]
one of them you know why because I can
see what she's been doing man no need
that's not it's all in the Life only
want to lie and they're walking around
town cause Tom just [__] you're someone
the Night Before Our Man does water in
the room not in a bad thing yeah
right no seriousness right and this is a
serious Auntie Jenny coming on now right
because users are talking so much
earlier that when they talk about body
care I I just zoned out the [__] that I
don't want to hear what it's not what to
say but that's why I asked the question
again
four at 18 there's nothing to be proud
right I'm telling you now because when I
heard the 15 before 30 that's where it
starts from so as far as I'm concerned
you see your four
keep it at four to your 30. no no no no
no no keep it at four don't be going out
and I'll date some winding up the guys
don't be going out and saying oh I'm
gonna go to you just in case right
because if I was a man and I took you
out and you're not freeing it out I'm
gonna feel offended especially if you're
not gonna go out for a date to look for
forward to having a relationship so you
see your four I want to hear from you
that in five years time it's too far
unless you got a ring on your finger in
10 years time that is still full unless
you've got your finger and your ring on
your finger right and take don't shut up
take advice from an older woman that
four but 18 is nothing to be talking
about right you need no stop I'll talk
to a young lady I'm trying to teach her
from all you men out there that wanna
[__] her stop do not have any more I'm
seriously I'm not you but men in general
I'm telling you I'm serious now 18.
when you think about the legal age is 16
please don't don't do it don't do it to
yourself I'm telling you right because
I'm trying to save you from yourself
don't listen to anybody else that's
telling you it's okay tell them that
Auntie Jenny said I've got to shut it
down from now on I tell you what you do
right DM me when you want to have sex
again and I will meet you wherever you
are I will drive 200 and whatever miles
and stop you from having sex anytime you
feel frisky you find that you're in a
relationship with a man call me and I
will come down there and I will cop
blocks
but I'm telling you because as if he was
my daughter you'd be coming home with me
now if you're living on your own I'll be
taking you home because four at 18. it's
disgusting it's disgusting
don't listen to them that are women and
they're telling you it's good if you
want to date tell them that Auntie Jenny
says I'm gonna shut my legs when I'm on
a date if you want a date with me just
talk to me but don't have no more sex
because the people out there and the
women that are teaching you that it's
okay they're telling you rubbish they're
lying to you you know why because
they're jealous of your youth so the
only thing you got now is your Youth and
your low body count so don't let no
older woman tell you no different keep
your body count Low by shutting your
legs concentrate on your career from now
on because when I heard four I put
myself it could possibly be you because
when I was like oh 25 I was on four and
you're 18 on four it's not good don't do
it don't listen to nobody and I'm
telling you the truth right if I can
drive 135 miles have sex with my man I
will drive 200 miles to [__] block you
it's so funny because that's what I
wanted to say because I couldn't believe
that before I had to check for and check
your age again that's why I've been
waiting it all quiet because I couldn't
believe that 18 year old I had my son at
your age
and that's where it stopped do you mean
one and my son at your age and you're
having four you're gonna have children
stop before you get pregnant and it
stops you don't have no money Auntie
Jenny why are you being like this though
no I agree with you
[Laughter]
hey no I know you're trying to shake it
off
she's not gonna do it to me my son's 37.
that could be my grandchild right now
listen I can't block him I know anywhere
you see her right any man wants to have
sex with this woman remember Auntie
Jenny be after you I've got you Mark I
do not have sex in this young woman
because she belongs to me
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible